in the paper they got a chance to look
at there's a section on ethical
considerations what's in that section
what are some ethical considerations
here is it some of the stuff we've
already talked about there's some things
that we've already talked about
um I think specific to diplomacy you
know there's there's also the the
challenge that the game is
you know there is a deception aspect to
the game
um and so
you know have developing language models
that are capable of deception is I think
a dicey issue and something that you
know makes research on diplomacy
particularly challenging
um and
you know so so those kinds of issues of
like should we even be developing AIS
that are capable of lying to people
that's something that we have to you
know think carefully about uh that's so
cool I mean that you have to do that
kind of stuff in order to figure out
where the ethical lines are but I can
see in the future it being illegal to
have a consumer product that
lies
yeah yeah like your personal assistant
AI system is not a lot is always have to
tell the truth but if if I ask it do I
do I look did I get fatter over the past
month I sure as hell want that AI system
to lie to me uh so there's a trade-off
between lying and being and being nice
after somehow find
where's the ethics in that and we're
back to discussions inside relationships
anyway what were you saying oh yeah I
was getting like yeah this yeah that's
kind of going to the question of like
what what is a lot you know is a white
lie a bad lie is it an ethical lie yeah
you know those kinds of questions uh boy
we return time and time again to deep
human questions as we design AI systems
that's exactly what they do they put a
mirror to humanity to help us understand
ourselves
there's there's also the issue of like
you know in these diplomacy experiments
in order to do
a fair comparison you know what we found
is that there's an inherent anti-ai bias
in these kinds of games so we actually
played a tournament in a non-language
version of the game where you know we we
told the participants like hey in every
single game there's going to be an AI
and what we found is that the humans
would spend basically the entire game
like trying to figure out who the bot
was and then as soon as they thought
they figured it out they would all team
up and try to kill it
um and you know overcoming that inherent
anti-ai bias is is a challenge um on the
flip side
I think when robots become the enemy
that's when we get to heal our human
divisions and then we can become one as
long as we have one enemy it's it's that
Reagan thing when aliens show up that's
when we we put our side our divisions
we've become one one human species right
we might have our differences but we're
at least all human at least we all hate
the robots no no no I think there will
be actually in the future something like
a civil rights movement for robots I
think that's the fascinating things
about AI systems and is they ask they
force us to ask about
ethical questions about what is
sentience what is uh how do we feel
about systems that are capable of
suffering or capable of displaying
suffering and how do we design products
that show emotion and not how do we feel
about that lying is another topic are we
going to allow Bots to lie and not and
where's the balance between being nice
and and telling the truth I mean these
are all fascinating human questions it's
like so exciting to be in the century
when we create systems that
take these philosophical questions that
have been asked for centuries and now we
can engineer them inside systems where
like you really have to answer them
because you'll have
transformational impact on human society
depending on what you design inside
those systems it's fascinating and like
you said I feel like diplomacy is a step
towards the direction of the real world
applying these RL methods towards the
real world
from from all the Breakthrough
performances and go and chess and
Starcraft and DOTA this is this feels
like the real world especially now my
mind's been on war in military conflict
this feels like it can give us some deep
insights about human behavior at the
large geopolitical scale